what's happening dude what are you doing
where are we right now
whose bed is this
what is it jarvan yeah are you sure
this looks like it's grandma's bed yeah
but that's my bed and oh you always say
that's stupid
this is yours yours and grandma's bed
yeah and what are we gonna do today go
to the park
go to the park
and then after the park what do we do
and how does that make you feel
why
oh man i'm so sorry duty
i left up oh okay i thought i thought he
was crying
i'm not gonna be here for a million days
for one million days yeah well you know
what we're gonna go home for a week so
that means only five days so it's a
business week
and then
that friday we're gonna come
back but where are we gonna stay
when will we go to vegas no no no
we're gonna stay here what are you
talking about don't wanna stay
oh how long how many days eight
long
days no i wanna million days we'll do it
well if we add them all together
they're still not going to be a million
dude there's only 365 days in a year
uh um
[Music]
well what if we break up that million
and we do eight days at a time
and then we add it all up okay
bad questions that's a bad question yeah
okay
good
what are you saying
these are my favorite part of taika
right here these guys
ever since you were bored these have
been my favorite little feet dude
you big bozo grandma has the comfiest
bed ever
it's
and then these sheets are so soft
it does sound a little bit noisy because
she does put it over here
she puts a little trash bag in case
somebody gets a little oxidant
this was my i think this was my
pregnancy pillow one of them or maybe
not maybe i made that up um
this is my potato man
my potato
why are you beating him up
and then take his little crackhead mouth
he's white because he was eating
powdered donuts this morning huh
monkey can i ask you a question
okay
okay ready can we sit up because i want
a serious talk
okay
monkey yeah
why do you like grandma's house so much
because because i always send me cousins
like seeing your cousins yeah yeah
yeah are they nice to you
no not that luck
okay so derek is one of the one of this
one of tycho's cousins
brother to brother to dominic's son to
my brother
um
and they're they're
paternal twins
born
months apart so they're really close in
age
um and derek is
literally
okay
why else do you like coming to grandma
so much stop why else do you like coming
to grandma's
because she
can't because
because she made my bed because cause
what do you miss me she makes her bed
yeah cause they put my stuffies nicely
she puts your stuffies nicely yeah you
can't eat it because you're ready did
you get your leche ready i'm a bed ready
and your bed ready yay
i got really bright in here
okay what's your question i have a funny
question okay what's your funny question
get it
uh because
i was walking
and then i fell down
on a person okay what's your question
that's your question yeah no that's not
the whole question that doesn't it
okay so now what's the question um
because i was walking around i thought
i'm a stranger thing you fell on a
stranger's face yeah
and then the kicks kicked the eyeball
okay
and then what happened
i went to my house and the shoes hurt
okay where's the question dude and i got
a gun and it's maximum jeep
on the cheek yeah what's going on right
here and then
and then i kissed him ew
on the bus oh
disgusting
okay where is the question monkey where
is the question at the end of the story
it's at the
at the end of the story it's episode
and the camera there and then
it's
okay and then where's the question and
that's the last one
[Music]
okay so i guess there's no question um
moving on
okay so i'm showered up
i'm so sleepy so that means i need some
coffee
and
um if you haven't been following any of
our fitness journey on barbell brigade
we just released a get lean program
and um in honor of the program bart and
i decided that we're going to start
getting lean
and we're going to run a competition
between us too
so the program is a 12 week program
and we're going to be running it so for
12 weeks we're going to be running that
program and also dieting to see who can
lose the most amount of fat but then
you're thinking but wait how do you guys
have the same amount of fat how do you
even determine that guys have less fat
than girls guys tend to lose fat faster
than girls don't worry we thought about
all of that stuff we actually got a dexa
scan which is the most
accurate technology that we have until
this point there's also like a different
like water scan but we didn't do any of
that we just kept it as simple and
accessible as possible and we did a dexa
scan each one of us and um that was
about two weeks ago so i've been running
the diet running the program and as part
of the diet i am tracking my macros or
macronutrients
which gives me an allowance of calories
that i can use per day
to help me
lose weight and eat right and eat
consistently and hit the right amount of
protein
and one of the things that
i discovered
while doing this is how to make really
delicious coffee
with super low calories and high protein
okay so i'm going to share that with you
now i don't know why my voice started
changing
so i'm actually my mom's house and she
has this dark roast i think it's nutella
i don't know it has a wow how is it not
advertised in here other than like there
but it has like a cinnamony taste to it
i don't know if that's the nutella bean
or what the hell it is but it tastes
cinnamon which is really really bomb
and i also bought some tarani uh sugar
free
syrup and i got it sugar free because
it's gonna be zero carbs zero calorie
zero ever sang
so that's not gonna add any calories and
this i think is only like
five calories or something
per
cup
but here is banger i get fair life
fat free
um milk
it's 80 calories
zero fat and 13 grams of protein and
lemon
i don't know if it's because i'm on a
diet and i've been deprived but this
tastes
so bomb this is a really bomb
combination so if you want some really
yummy a coffee super low calories 13
grams of protein then i suggest this
trio i gotta remind this for myself
because i need to buy this when i get
home and what are you eating over there
a lollipop
taika
is so sad
because we have to leave grandma's house
okay
wait it's only for five days monkey then
we'll be back for eight days
okay okay
okay i will here
okay go go say your goodbyes to grandma
it's [ __ ] cute i think it's the
cutest [ __ ] how much they love each
other my mom literally cries every time
we leave back to vegas
and um
i'm like well we're gonna be back in a
week but she's so sentimental and tech
it like is the exact same way look at
him he's so sad
but it makes my heart really happy
you hear him makes my heart really happy
that he loves her so much and he feels
so much love here so
gotta go deal with that baby
be right back y'all
papa yeah monkey mama so i didn't grow
up with the grandma yeah
like that at least or that close yeah
but when you see tucker go through the
same thing of like
feeling sad and crying and stuff yeah
you say you can relate yeah i could
relate really hard
what do you relate to
well like my grandma was super duper
cuny
and she was super warm
and i think like with parents since like
they have the responsibility of like
raising the kids you gotta teach them
rules you gotta enforce the rules you
gotta guide them a lot of stuff like
that like um the time that you spend
with your parents half of it is being
like
raised and educated you know but with
your grandparents since none of that is
really their responsibility it's just
like all love it's just like it's like
the most warmest feeling like i remember
like crawling into my grandma's bed like
her bed felt more comfortable even
though it was rock hard her robe like
was probably stinky but i loved it i
just had like this and then like my
grandma asked me what i want to eat and
then she'd make me the best food all the
food that my parents couldn't make she
would make so it just felt like the
whole world was like like fluffified you
know like all cuny and funny and warm
and fuzzy and stuff
and so like when i see tyka um you know
say bye to grandma and he's just like
this grandmother so much like i know
exactly
how that feels that's how i felt about
my grandma especially my mom's mom which
grandma is your his mom's mom you know
yeah
it is lunchtime now we are in the city
of glendora on our way back home to
vegas
the monkey dude is out
i bet that dude had so much fun this
whole week in california because all he
does is play and like he doesn't take
naps because he's just playing all day
it's super sick
i love his little childhood
um
but lunch on a diet hit a bit different
not to learn and we didn't cook anything
so um
lucky for us we live in a time now
where the internet exists and people
have been running macros and these types
of diets for a minute now that they've
created like different
uh sheets of like fast food restaurants
that are macro or diet friendly
um and chipotle is one of those and
chipotle caught wind of you know people
on diets going to their restaurant that
they even have a nutrition calculator
and it looks like this so for anyone
else that's running their macros i
highly recommend that you get this
so it tells you your fat protein and
carbs which are your macronutrients and
then it tells you what each one is i
opted for chicken you can get double
check out how the numbers change not 64
grams of protein
uh only 14 grams of fat and then zero
carbs
then i go to
tortilla which i don't want a tortilla
i'll get white rice
so as you can see it's super
customizable
and then at the end it'll tell you
um
i think that's why
yeah
and then it tells you at the end
what it is pretty cool right so it tells
you
760 calories
20 fat 77 protein which is in a [ __ ]
beautiful ratio here
um because usually i try to go 2 to 1 2
protein to one fat
and then
your carbs are 74.
so yeah check this out
so yeah that's what we're having for
lunch
and voila here's the order
apple got himself a burrito
with no beans
no rice
just veggies and salsa and protein oh my
god is it
bad it's not magical it's actually
really good that's not bad but it's just
not the support way that i know and love
with the extra extra guacamole i know
walk is so fatty
do you know
what drive-thru this is can you tell
where we're at
i'll give you a second
did you guess it right did you
did you guess it right
thank you
look at that hold it straight like this
there you go look at that smile look at
that smile
make sure you hold it straight okay
because if you tilt it if you tilt it
it's going to come out there you go
no don't drop it be very careful
is there anything else coming out of
that window
no
is there anything else
i wish did you know what i just saw i
have a new pretzel chocolate and caramel
mcflurry
for a limited time
why did you have to tell me you just
asked me
if anything else is coming out the
window that's it that's all i asked you
why would you torture me nothing but
potentially that
and we are finally home
it feels so good to be back home the
heat over here is pretty gnarly but
because it's dry it feels less hot
that are here than it did in california
but it's still hot nonetheless it's 102
over here where california was i think
90. um but one thing that i decided to
do this time that i never did before and
i don't know why i didn't do this is we
usually leave on we usually leave my
mom's house
on sunday and then i come home and then
you know all the clothes that we wore
while we were there i go up and i wash
it right this time i was like mom can i
borrow your washing machine and i washed
all of our clothes
folded it put it on nice and neat all i
have to do is transfer it from my bag
in to our drawers and closets and i'm
done and i'm so excited that i did that
the only bummer is that i do have to
unpack but
at least it's going
away
and it's so [ __ ] hot i don't know if
you can see i'm like sweating everywhere
i keep like wiping it all off
i'ma chill a little bit okay
as you can see i still have to unpack
but before we even got home
we really do try to to set ourselves up
for success and because i keep talking
about freaking dieting that we're doing
um we didn't want to get home get super
relaxed and comfortable and then start
like becoming vegetables so
before we got home we went to our
favorite local
food spot and we stocked up for the week
so now we have all of our
um
all of our
trying to pull one out all of our diet
meals ready to rock
so that it makes it really hard to want
to have these gnarly cravings
and then you know kind of go back on our
diet i also went ahead and i cleaned out
all
the old food that we have which we
didn't have much because before we left
or actually the week
prior to us leaving to california just
make sure i didn't buy more food and
whatever i did have in here we brought a
big ass cooler to my mom's house
and packed all that stuff
as you can see hey
as you can see here
i did bring
food with us my mom doesn't want any of
this crap because it's diet food so then
i just brought it right back
but yeah any way i can help you achieve
your goals
that has has helped me i'm definitely
going to share it with you um another
thing i really do try to do is i try to
keep taika on
i like that i like him taking
vitamins so i bought him this little
pack it helps him
learn
the days of the week all while being
responsible and taking his
multivites which i do like to get ready
for him every sunday so that when he
starts on monday
he's ready to rock too so
trying to set ourselves up for the
beginning of the week
now so that we can coast the rest of the
night
chill out probably get some froyo
cause that's super low on fat um watch a
little movie as you can see tech has
already made himself at home he's there
taika
taika put your hand up
take it put your hand up
put your hand up i can't see it there he
is
yeah taiko without missing a bee he's
already back
back and ready to party
so yeah that's what i'm doing now
he's dead
so the sun is setting right over the
mountain
and me and tyke are about to watch and i
have a question what's your question i
want to get to nighttime everything's a
bit darker yeah and let's do it better
yeah
what are we about to watch
transforms to cars and trucks this is
just called transformers
but i have one of those okay let's watch
it yeah i'll show you okay ready